ハァ...ハァ...ハァ...
歳を感じる
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん蛇は好きでしょうか
僕爬虫類系は基本的に大丈夫なんですよ
トカゲとか…
トカゲ...は
やっぱりあまり得意ではありません
イグアナは好きなんです
イグアナは好きなんですけど
爬虫類系が…
あんまり得意じゃなくて
その中でも特に苦手なのが
白い蛇ってなんか
かみがみしさ(?)
神々しさがあるじゃないですか
そもそも蛇が駄目なんだけどね
ニョロニョロしてるあの感じがすごい苦手で
で、そんな　蛇が苦手なんですけども
白蛇が特に苦手
怖い
神の分身みたいなこと言われてるじゃないですか
僕昔 家の近くに神社があるんですけど
三歳くらいの時その神社の裏に
白蛇がいて
その蛇に石ころ投げたら
当たっちゃって
その一週間後…
ほぼ全部の歯が虫歯になりました
バチが当たりました
ってぐらい　白蛇にはすごい
恐怖心が僕の中にはあるんすよ
皆さんにあるかわかんないですけど
僕はあります
白蛇が超苦手なんですけども
今回は
こちらの紙粘土を使って
今回は超巨大な
白い大蛇を作っていこうと思います
怖いなー
今、残念ながらまさきがいないんで
仕掛けれないんですけど
他の後輩に
今からおいらん家に来るんですけど
家に入ってきたら
超巨大な大蛇がいるドッキリを
仕掛けていこうと思います
では行こう
ひとまず開けよう
～♪
よし
開けていきましょう！
（臭いよぉ...）
カアァァァァ！！！！！
～♪
よし全部出ました！
うわ～重！
うわ！やばこれ！
重い重い！
10キロある
あぁあぁ
あ～
まずはこねよう!
すご！うわっはｗ
うわすごいこれ！
うわああぁあ
すごいよー！！
臭！！
バァン！
という上でかなり伸ばすことができました
ここから、
なるべくこう捏ねて長く伸ばしてみようとおもいます。
一回半分に切った方がいいな。
おｋ×3
これを頑張って伸ばしていきます。
尻尾でなるべくリアリティーを出さないとたぶんねダメな気がします。
え！？
なんで消えた？
なんで消えた！？
は！？×2
何で何で？
なんでなんで？
え～今なんで消えた？
うわ～やっぱね、怖いんだよなー白ヘビ系なんか俺不吉なんだよな～
出来ました！
え普通にやばいと思うんだけど
尻尾とかだって完全ｎ..ちょっとちょっと
動きに弱い
動きに弱いわ
はいちょっと動きに弱いんですけどこちらのね、巨大白ヘビをつかって、
今から後輩が上がってくるんで、
軽くね、　威嚇してやろうと思います。
では行くぜ!
ピ～ンポ～ン♪
あぁ、上上、上にいるよ～
うえぇぇぇえぇぇぇぇ(汗)
なんだそのリアクションはアァァ！！！！
はじめ：え、ビビんなかった？
後輩：割とビビりましたｗ
はじめ：ビビったあぁぁあｗｗｗｗ
後輩：え、めっちゃビビりましたでしょ？
ビビったっしょ？
ビビったならいいともｗｗｗ